When was the last time you misplaced your keys, glasses, or cell phone? Or ran into an acquaintance and couldn't come up with their name no matter how hard you racked your brain? Have you ever gotten into an argument with a sibling over whether a childhood memory really happened the way you thought it did? Both of you sure that your memory was correct? Human memory is imperfect. For most people, it's easy to think of examples of these common but frustrating situations.
你上一次弄丢钥匙、眼镜或手机是什么时候？或者遇到熟人，无论怎么绞尽脑汁也想不起对方的名字？你是否曾因为童年记忆是否真的如你所想的那样发生过，而与兄弟姐妹发生过争执？你们俩都确信自己的记忆是正确的？人类的记忆是不完美的。对大多数人来说，很容易想到这些常见但令人沮丧的情况。
For the past several decades, psychologists have begun to gain a better understanding of how our brains remember, misremember, and forget. So why is our memory so fallible? What are the most common memory errors and what are their consequences? How does memory change as we age? Is there anything we can do to improve our memory or keep it sharp? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Daniel Schachter, a professor of psychology at Harvard University. His research uses the tools of psychology and neuroscience to study how memory works and why it is so often prone to error and distortion.
在过去的几十年里，心理学家开始更好地理解我们的大脑是如何记忆、错误记忆和遗忘的。那么，为什么我们的记忆如此不可靠？最常见的记忆错误是什么？它们会带来什么后果？随着年龄的增长，记忆会发生怎样的变化？我们能做些什么来改善记忆或保持头脑敏锐吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是哈佛大学心理学教授丹尼尔·沙克特博士。他的研究利用心理学和神经科学的工具来研究记忆是如何运作的，以及为什么它经常容易出错和扭曲。
His 2001 book, The Seven Sins of Memory, categorized and explained the most common memory failures. A 20th anniversary edition of the book is due out in September, and it includes updates on how our understanding of memory has advanced over the past two decades. It also explores new topics, including how technology may be affecting our memory and how memory is intertwined with our ability to plan for the future. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Shachter. Nice to be here. So, as I said, your book is called The Seven Sins of Memory. Can you, first of all, talk about those sins are why you call them sins, and some of them are, as you say, sins of omission and sins of commission. What are the differences?
他2001年的著作《记忆的七宗罪》对最常见的记忆失败进行了分类和解释。该书的20周年纪念版将于9月出版，其中包含了过去二十年来我们对记忆的理解是如何进步的最新内容。它还探讨了新的主题，包括技术可能如何影响我们的记忆，以及记忆如何与我们规划未来的能力交织在一起。感谢您参加我们的节目，沙克特博士。很高兴来到这里。那么，正如我所说，您的书名为《记忆的七宗罪》。首先，您能谈谈这些“罪”是什么，为什么称它们为“罪”吗？正如您所说，其中一些是“遗漏之罪”和“犯错之罪”。它们之间有什么区别？
Back around 2000, 1999, as I was kind of surveying the literary. on memory errors, it struck me that while psychologists had known for decades, that memory is prone to error, nobody had really tried to organize our knowledge and try to suggest the way of classifying these errors. And my best take on the literature was that there are these seven basic categories of memory errors. And so by analogy with the well-known seven ancient deadly sins, I couldn't resist calling them the seven sins of memory. So there are three sins of omission, different kinds of forgetting, four sins of commission when memory is present, but either wrong or intrusive. So the three sins of omission I call transients. That's forgetting
大约在2000年、1999年，当我正在梳理关于记忆错误的文献时，我突然想到，尽管心理学家几十年来一直知道记忆容易出错，但没有人真正尝试过整理我们的知识并提出一种分类这些错误的方法。我对文献的最佳理解是，记忆错误有这七个基本类别。因此，类比于众所周知的古代七宗罪，我忍不住称它们为“记忆的七宗罪”。所以有三种“遗漏之罪”，即不同类型的遗忘；四种“犯错之罪”，即记忆存在，但要么是错误的，要么是侵入性的。所以我称这三种遗漏之罪为“短暂性”。这就是随时间推移而产生的遗忘。
over time. We all know from our everyday experience that all other things being equal, we tend to remember experiences and information that are recent in time better than those that occurred long ago. Memories tend to fade over time. The second sin of omission I call absent-mindedness. So this is not memory fading over time. This is kind of a breakdown at the interface of memory and attention. So we may be distracted, focused on.
我们从日常经验中都知道，在其他条件相同的情况下，我们往往比很久以前发生的经历和信息更容易记住最近的经历和信息。记忆往往会随着时间的推移而消退。我称第二种遗漏之罪为“心不在焉”。这不是记忆随时间消退，而是记忆与注意力接口处的一种崩溃。所以我们可能会分心，专注于
upcoming tasks and we put our keys down. We don't notice where we put those keys down. The event really never gets into memory. That would be an absent-minded kind of forgetting. Or we may put our keys down and know exactly where they are, but then we're distracted at the time of retrieval and we walk out the door without our keys. That would be another example of absent-mindedness. Third kind of forgetting sins, sin of omission I call blocking. This is when memories available, it hasn't faded away over time. We're trying to remember, doing our best to remember, but we can't come up with information that's actually stored in memory,
即将到来的任务，然后我们放下钥匙。我们没有注意到把钥匙放在哪里了。这件事实际上从未进入记忆。那将是一种心不在焉的遗忘。或者我们可能放下钥匙，确切地知道它们在哪里，但随后在检索时分心了，我们出门时没带钥匙。那将是心不在焉的另一个例子。我称第三种遗忘罪，即遗漏之罪为“阻塞”。这是指记忆是可用的，它并没有随时间消退。我们试图记住，尽最大努力去记住，但我们无法提取出实际上存储在记忆中的信息，
and that I call blocking. So those are three sins of omission. Sins of co-mission, one I call misattribution. So this is when we recall some aspect of an event correctly, but we get the source wrong. So we might recall someone told us this interesting fact and we might remember what the fact is and say that it was my cousin who told me that
我称之为阻塞。所以这就是三种遗漏之罪。犯错之罪，我称之为“错误归因”。这是指当我们正确地回忆起事件的某个方面，但搞错了来源。所以我们可能回忆起有人告诉我们这个有趣的事实，我们可能记得这个事实是什么，并说是我表弟告诉我的，
when in fact it was somebody else or I actually heard it on the radio. So we misattribute the source. Related to that is something I call suggestibility. This is when misinformation is suggested to us. We incorporate that into our memory, So a suggestion about something that might have happened in the past that didn't happen becomes incorporated into our memories and we're prone to this kind of sin of suggestibility,
而实际上是别人告诉我的，或者我实际上是在收音机里听到的。所以我们错误地归因了来源。与此相关的是我称之为“暗示性”的东西。这是指当我们被暗示了错误信息时。我们将其纳入我们的记忆中，所以关于过去可能发生但实际上并未发生的某事的暗示被纳入了我们的记忆，我们很容易犯这种暗示性的罪，
which can be very dangerous. And then the third kind of distortion-related sin I call bias. And this refers to how our current knowledge, beliefs, and feelings impact and sometimes skewer, distort our past memories. And then the final seven sin, I call it. I call persistence, and that refers to intrusive memories. This is typically something that happens when we've had an emotion or even traumatic experience and we just can't get it out of our mind. We have these very persistent memories.
这可能非常危险。然后我称第三种与扭曲相关的罪为“偏见”。这指的是我们当前的知识、信念和感受如何影响，有时甚至歪曲、扭曲我们过去的记忆。然后是第七种罪，我称之为“持续性”，它指的是侵入性记忆。这通常发生在我们有过某种情绪甚至创伤经历时，我们就是无法将其从脑海中抹去。我们有这些非常持续的记忆。
So those are the seven. So one of the most frustrating memory failures that a lot of us experience is that tip of the tongue feeling when we're trying to remember someone's name or a word and we just can't pull it out. why does this happen and when it does, is there anything that we can do that will help us retrieve the lost word? One of the things we know is that we tend to be vulnerable to tip of the tongue experiences for information that's available in memory, but we haven't used recently. So it's there for sure, but we haven't brought it to mind recently. It becomes harder to retrieve. And we may be even able to
所以这就是那七宗罪。那么，我们许多人经历过的最令人沮丧的记忆失败之一就是当我们试图记住某人的名字或一个词时，那种“话到嘴边”的感觉，但我们就是想不起来。为什么会发生这种情况？当它发生时，我们能做些什么来帮助我们检索丢失的词吗？我们知道的一件事是，对于记忆中可用但我们最近没有使用过的信息，我们往往容易出现“话到嘴边”的体验。所以它肯定在那里，但我们最近没有想到它。它变得更难检索。我们甚至可能能够
recall certain aspects of the information, so we can't come up with someone's name, but we are able to remember all, you know, many things about them. And one reason why the name in particular seems to be the most susceptible to tip of the tongue, particularly as we get older, and that's because in part a name is not inherently meaningful. So there was an experiment done a number of years ago, known as the Baker-Baker experiment, and basically showed that if you're trying to remember the name of someone named John Baker, you're much more prone to tip of the tongue than if you're trying to recall the term Baker. So it's Baker in both cases. In one case, you've got all kinds of semantic information closely integrated to the name.
回忆起信息的某些方面，所以我们想不起某人的名字，但我们能够记住关于他们的所有，你知道，很多事情。名字特别容易出现“话到嘴边”的情况，尤其是随着我们年龄的增长，原因之一是名字本质上是没有意义的。所以几年前做过一个实验，被称为“贝克-贝克实验”，基本上表明，如果你试图记住一个叫约翰·贝克的人的名字，你比试图回忆“面包师”（Baker）这个词更容易出现“话到嘴边”的情况。所以两种情况下都是Baker。在一种情况下，你拥有与名字紧密结合的各种语义信息。
And in another case of the proper name, there's nothing inherently meaningful about that. But one thing we can do to try to prevent that because it really does seem to occur most often for information that we haven't retrieved recently or frequently. For example, if you're going to a party and you know you're going to see people at the party who you haven't seen recently and you might anticipate possibly feeling embarrassed if you can't come up with the name of someone who you've met before, you haven't seen recently, kind of review the names of people who are going. You can. Or a parent who is going to a school function is going to see other parents.
而在专有名词的另一种情况下，它本身并没有什么内在意义。但我们可以做的一件事是试图防止这种情况，因为它确实似乎最常发生在那些我们最近或不经常检索的信息上。例如，如果你要去参加一个聚会，你知道你会见到最近没见过的人，如果你想不起以前见过但最近没见过的人的名字，你可能会感到尴尬，可以预先复习一下要去的人的名字。你可以。或者一个要去参加学校活动的家长会见到其他家长。
They don't see these people very often. They feel like they should know the names, but you can anticipate the possibility of an embarrassing tip of the tongue. Review the material in advance and that can really help with a problem. Once the tip of the tongue is started, then it's too late in most cases to do much about it. Sometimes just waiting. The information will come over time.
他们不经常见到这些人。他们觉得他们应该知道名字，但你可以预见到出现尴尬的“话到嘴边”的可能性。提前复习材料，这真的可以帮助解决这个问题。一旦“话到嘴边”开始了，在大多数情况下，做太多补救已经太晚了。有时只是等待。信息会随着时间推移而出现。
We all know that experience. It comes a day later. It's as if you've sent the signal that takes time to percolate in the brain. But I think the proactive strategy, when it can be used, can be effective. So my technique of just faking it and not saying the person's name and hoping that somebody else will walk up and say, hey, John, then I'll get it. That's not really a good solution. Well, it's not a solution, but we've all done that because those are exactly. the situations in which this is most likely to occur.
我们都知道那种经历。它会在一天后出现。就好像你发出了一个信号，需要时间在大脑中渗透。但我认为，当可以使用时，主动策略是有效的。所以我那种假装认识、不说对方名字、希望别人走过来叫一声“嘿，约翰”然后我就能想起来的技术，那并不是一个很好的解决方案。好吧，这不是一个解决方案，但我们都这样做过，因为这些正是最容易发生这种情况的情况。
So that raises in my mind the question about where we store certain kinds of memories. So are names in a particular place and say numbers are somewhere else and images of, I don't know, I don't know, landscape, but it's someplace else. Do we know? Yeah, I think we do know. We do know that there are elements of memory storage that have the character that you just described. They're kind of distributed in different parts of the brain. different kinds of information, different features of an experience. They're not just sitting in one spot in the brain, and then suddenly there's a explosion,
这在我的脑海中引发了一个关于我们将某些类型的记忆存储在哪里的问题。那么名字是在特定的地方，比如数字在别处，图像，我不知道，风景，是在别处吗？我们知道吗？是的，我想我们知道。我们确实知道记忆存储的要素具有您刚才描述的特征。它们分布在大脑的不同部分。不同类型的信息，体验的不同特征。它们不仅仅是坐在大脑的一个点上，然后突然发生爆炸，
and that's the memory. You have to pull together information stored in different parts of the brain. And for quite a while now, people, researchers have thought that there's a particular region that's important for helping us to pull together those. distributed bits of information, and that's the hippocampus. The key region for memory, spatial function, and we know that when the hippocampus is damaged, you're going to have a significant memory problem.
那就是记忆。你必须把存储在大脑不同部分的信息拉到一起。很长一段时间以来，人们，研究人员认为有一个特定的区域对于帮助我们把那些分散的信息片段拉到一起很重要，那就是海马体。记忆、空间功能的关键区域，我们知道当海马体受损时，你会有严重的记忆问题。
And although people are still debating exactly what's the best way to characterize the functions of the hippocampus, one of the things that it does is help us to pull together bits and pieces of information that are stored in different parts of the brain. And that underscores the fundamental point about memory that it's really a constructive process. It's not just simply a matter of reactivating a picture in the mind. It's a much more constructive process than that.
尽管人们仍在争论表征海马体功能的最佳方式究竟是什么，但它所做的事情之一就是帮助我们把存储在大脑不同部分的零碎信息拉到一起。这强调了关于记忆的一个基本点，即它确实是一个构建过程。它不仅仅是简单地重新激活脑海中的一幅画面。它是一个比那更具构建性的过程。
Let's talk a little bit about one of the sins of a mission that you mentioned earlier, transients. Why do our memories fade over time? and why don't we remember, say, our earliest childhood? There are a number of reasons why memories fade over time. One of them is that we simply don't rehearse the memory. There's kind of a use-it-or-lose-it principle in memory, such that experiences, facts that we retrieve,
让我们谈谈您之前提到的遗漏之罪之一，“短暂性”。为什么我们的记忆会随时间消退？为什么我们记不住，比如说，我们最早的童年？记忆随时间消退的原因有很多。其中之一是我们根本没有复习记忆。记忆中有一种“用进废退”的原则，即我们检索的经历、事实，
we reflect back on are those that tend to persist, whereas experiences that we don't retrieve after an event has occurred, tend to all things being equal, fade away. And that kind of makes sense from an adaptive perspective in that the things that are really important to are so things we're going to be more likely to retrieve again in the future, and that kind of boosts them and prevents them from fading over time. One of the really interesting things that we've learned in the last 20 years, and it's one of the findings that I highlighted in the update section on transients and related to what we're just discussing, is that there's a technique referred to as in the literature sometimes as retrieval practice. It's also known as the testing effect. Although this was discovered in some form many over a century ago, it's only real in the last time. 20 years that psychologists have really characterized and really studied intensively this effect.
我们回顾的那些往往会持续存在，而我们在事件发生后没有检索的经历，在其他条件相同的情况下，往往会消退。从适应的角度来看，这很有道理，因为那些真正重要的事情是我们未来更有可能再次检索的事情，这会增强它们并防止它们随时间消退。我们在过去20年中学到的非常有趣的事情之一，也是我在关于短暂性的更新部分中强调的发现，并且与我们刚才讨论的内容相关，那就是文献中有时被称为“检索练习”的技术。它也被称为“测试效应”。尽管这种效应在某种形式上在一个多世纪前就被发现了，但只是在过去20年里，心理学家才真正表征并深入研究了这种效应。
Basically, what this refers to is the idea that, for example, suppose you read a story. Later on, you could either restudy parts of that story to help you remember it better in the future, or I could test you on parts of the story. And what has been found is that if you get tested, that really provides a long, long-term boost to the memory such that you forget over time much more slowly. So testing versus restudding reduces the transience of memory, which I think is a very interesting finding and consistent with what I was saying before, that information that we retrieve tends to persist more into the future. And the forgetting curve or the curve of transients in the terms of the
基本上，这指的是这样一个想法，例如，假设你读了一个故事。稍后，你可以重新学习那个故事的部分内容以帮助你在未来更好地记住它，或者我可以测试你关于那个故事的部分内容。研究发现，如果你接受测试，那确实会为记忆提供长期的提升，这样你随时间推移遗忘的速度会慢得多。因此，测试与重新学习相比，减少了记忆的短暂性，我认为这是一个非常有趣的发现，并且与我之前所说的一致，即我们检索的信息往往会更多地持续到未来。而遗忘曲线或《记忆的七宗罪》中短暂性的曲线，
Seven Sins of Memory is much less steep when we retrieve and test ourselves. So there are a couple of lessons there. One, for example, for students, and I think this is becoming pretty widely known now, that for preparing for a test, self-testing versus just restudying the same thing over and over again can be really helpful, particularly for boosting long-term learning. There's another tie-in to this, and this is something in memory that has been observed only, again, during the last 20 years, and I talk about it in one of the update sections of the new Seven Sins book coming out, is an interesting group of people who some listeners may be familiar with because they've been shown on 60 Minutes and other TV shows who are associated with the condition known as highly superior autobiographical memory. So these are people who seem to be able to remember events from their personal past from a long time ago with an uncanny ability. So if you ask one of these folks, you know, what happened to you on May 17, 1998, chances are they're going to be able to tell you that.
当我们检索和测试自己时，陡峭程度要低得多。所以那里有几个教训。例如，对于学生来说，我认为这现在已经广为人知了，为了准备考试，自我测试与一遍又一遍地重新学习同样的东西相比，真的很有帮助，特别是对于提升长期学习效果。这还有另一个关联，这是记忆中观察到的东西，同样，仅在过去20年里，我在即将出版的新版《七宗罪》的更新章节中谈到了它，是一群有趣的人，一些听众可能很熟悉，因为他们曾在《60分钟》和其他电视节目中出现过，他们与一种被称为“超强自传体记忆”的状况有关。所以这些人似乎能够以一种不可思议的能力记住很久以前个人过去的事件。所以如果你问这些人中的一个，你知道，1998年5月17日发生了什么，他们很有可能能够告诉你。
And of course, most of us, if we're asked what happened to us on May 17, 1998, unless it's our birthday or some highly, the significant date are going to have no clue what happened to us then. And there are a number of these people have now been identified. They've been studied with both brain scanning and psychological studies and tying into our discussion of transients. What seems to be happening with these folks is that they have a much less deep forgetting curve for personal experiences. So if you ask them about something that happened yesterday,
当然，我们大多数人，如果我们被问到1998年5月17日发生了什么，除非那是我们的生日或某个高度重要的日期，否则我们将完全不知道那天发生了什么。现在已经确定了许多这样的人。他们已经通过脑部扫描和心理学研究进行了研究，并与我们关于短暂性的讨论联系起来。这些人的情况似乎是，他们对个人经历的遗忘曲线要平缓得多。所以如果你问他们昨天发生的事情，
their memory is not going to be much different from my memory or your memory or anybody else's memory. But that memory doesn't fade over time. And they don't have a photographic memory. They're prone to various kinds of memory distortions and errors just like everybody else. The memory holds up well over time. And the reason for that may link back to what we were just talking about about the testing effect. A lot of these people tend to retrieve and rehash their personal memories quite extensively.
他们的记忆与我的记忆或你的记忆或任何其他人的记忆不会有太大不同。但那种记忆不会随时间消退。他们没有照相式记忆。他们像其他人一样容易出现各种记忆扭曲和错误。记忆随时间保持得很好。其原因可能与我们刚才谈到的测试效应有关。这些人中的许多人倾向于非常广泛地检索和重温他们的个人记忆。
And so it may be kind of an extreme form of self-testing that is preventing these memories from fading over time. We did an episode just a few weeks back on that very topic and had a guest, we had a researcher who works in the area and a guest who has highly superior autobiographical memory. And one of the interesting things that she said was that the pandemic, the COVID pandemic and the lockdowns had an effect on her memory. She talked about the fact that because the days were all so similar and blended together that she had lost track and she really felt like her H-SAM was very attenuated. And I'm just thinking, is that going to happen to all of us? I mean, should we all
所以这可能是一种极端的自我测试形式，正在防止这些记忆随时间消退。几周前我们做了一期关于这个主题的节目，请了一位嘉宾，我们有一位在该领域工作的研究人员和一位拥有超强自传体记忆的嘉宾。她说的一件有趣的事情是，大流行，新冠大流行和封锁对她的记忆产生了影响。她谈到了这样一个事实，因为日子都太相似了，混在一起，她失去了踪迹，她真的觉得她的H-SAM（超强自传体记忆）非常减弱。我只是在想，这会发生在我们所有人身上吗？我的意思是，我们都应该
expect that there's a kind of a big blur for the last, you know, however long this is going to last? I think so. In fact, that's very interesting to me that that was. what happened to a person with H-HM, but it makes a lot of sense for the reasons you describe. I think that going into and coming out of the pandemic, we're probably going to see something along the lines you describe that fits with what psychologists have studied for years and is known as a serial position curve. So we tend to have really good memories like in a standard wordless memory experiment in the laboratory.
期待过去这段时间会有一种模糊感吗？我想是的。事实上，对我来说，发生在一个拥有H-SAM的人身上是非常有趣的，但对于你描述的原因来说，这是非常有道理的。我认为在进入和走出大流行时，我们可能会看到一些符合心理学家多年来研究的内容，即所谓的“序列位置曲线”。所以我们往往在实验室的标准无词记忆实验中，
we remember the first few words in the list very well, then we don't remember the stuff in the middle so much, and we remember the last couple at the end. Similarly, I think that probably most of us will have like a vivid memory of what happened, you know, in March 2020, where everything changed and, you know, went to work one day and then we didn't the next day. I, you know, I have my own memory of that when the COVID onset. But then for exactly the reasons you described, we didn't. don't have, you know, the normal event boundaries or segmentation or going on vacation,
我们能很好地记住列表中的前几个词，然后我们记不住中间的东西，我们能记住最后几个。同样，我认为我们大多数人可能会对2020年3月发生的事情有生动的记忆，当时一切都变了，你知道，有一天去上班，然后第二天就没有了。我，你知道，我自己也有关于新冠爆发时的记忆。但随后正是因为你描述的原因，我们没有
going out to dinner, all the things that allow us to make one event distinctive from another. And so I would expect a kind of blurring for all these experiences in the middle of COVID. And then maybe, you know, some recovery at the end, we remember, oh, the first time I, you know, I went on a restaurant, went to a restaurant as the pandemic was easing. or the first time I went back on an airplane. So, but it's very interesting for me to hear that that extends to someone with age set. Most people think that memory gets worse as we age. Is that backed up by the research and do people have better,
正常的事件边界或分割，或者去度假，出去吃晚餐，所有那些让我们能够将一个事件与另一个事件区分开来的事情。所以我预计在新冠疫情期间的所有这些经历都会有一种模糊感。然后也许，你知道，在最后会有一些恢复，我们记得，哦，大流行缓解时我第一次去餐馆，或者我第一次坐飞机。所以，但听到这延伸到拥有H-SAM的人身上，对我来说非常有趣。大多数人认为记忆会随着年龄的增长而变差。这有研究支持吗？人们有更好的，
do younger people always have better memories than older adults? I think in general it's backed up by the research, but it depends what kind of memory you're talking about. So, for example, semantic memory, our general, you know, our store of general knowledge, facts, associations, that holds up very well with age. And older adults can sometimes be as good as younger adults in, you know, accessing general knowledge or even better. What tends to really fade with age more is episodic memory, what we think of as memory for specific personal experiences. And the extent of age-related memory loss there depends on a host of factors.
年轻人总是比老年人有更好的记忆力吗？我认为总的来说，它得到了研究的支持，但这取决于你谈论的是哪种记忆。例如，语义记忆，我们一般的，你知道，我们的通用知识、事实、关联的存储，随着年龄的增长保持得非常好。老年人有时在获取通用知识方面可以和年轻人一样好，甚至更好。随着年龄增长而真正消退更多的是情景记忆，我们认为是特定个人经历的记忆。而那里与年龄相关的记忆丧失程度取决于许多因素。
So, for example, as we get older, we tend to have more difficulty retrieving information on our own without cues. But if we can be given effective cues, then older adults can often remember at or close to the level of younger adults. So it's not a, you know, a one-year-olds. So it's not a, you know, a one-size-fits-all kind of situation with aging. It very much depends on the specific circumstances and the kind of memory that we're talking about. So you mentioned cues as things that can help people to remember, which raises in my mind the question of what's happening to us with the advent of so many new technologies. Are technologies like GPS and the Internet affecting our memories? Is it harming our memories because we can look up everything that we want on Google?
例如，随着我们年龄的增长，我们在没有线索的情况下独立检索信息往往会更困难。但如果我们能得到有效的线索，那么老年人通常可以记住达到或接近年轻人的水平。所以这不是一个，你知道，一岁的人。所以这不是一个“一刀切”的衰老情况。它在很大程度上取决于具体情况和我们正在谈论的记忆类型。所以你提到线索是可以帮助人们记住的东西，这在我的脑海中引发了一个问题，即随着这么多新技术的出现，我们正在发生什么。GPS和互联网等技术是否在影响我们的记忆？因为我们可以在谷歌上查找我们想要的一切，这是否在损害我们的记忆？
I mean, you know, you don't have to remember the multiplication tables anymore, right? You don't have to remember anything. Just go to Google. Right. It's a great question, and it's, it is really an issue that's only coming to the four over the past 20 years, and it's one of the issues that I delve into in one of the updates in the Seventh Sins. And I think there was a lot of angst out there about the potentially negative effects of technology, media, the internet on memory for the reasons that you state. We have these other options. Maybe our memory systems are kind of dry up and we won't be using them in the way we have and therefore they're going to be less effective when we try to use them. My read on the literature is that the situation isn't as dire as
我的意思是，你知道，你不再需要记住乘法表了，对吧？你不需要记住任何东西。只要去谷歌就行了。对。这是一个很好的问题，而且它确实是一个在过去20年里才凸显出来的问题，这是我在《七宗罪》的更新之一中深入探讨的问题之一。我认为外面有很多关于技术、媒体、互联网对记忆的潜在负面影响的焦虑，原因正如你所说。我们有这些其他选择。也许我们的记忆系统会枯竭，我们将不会以我们过去的方式使用它们，因此当我们尝试使用它们时，它们的效果会变差。我对文献的解读是，情况并不像
Some make it out to be. You know, you read headlines, why the Internet is killing your memory or how the Internet is ruining your memory. I don't see a lot of evidence yet that that's happened. So, you know, I looked at studies on Google, studies on reviewing photographs, you know, through Instagram, use of GPS, things like media multitasking, where we may. you know, be distracted from paying attention from a lecture, for example, by activities on our smartphone. And what I concluded is the following. I think that there is no doubt evidence that when we rely on technology, our memory for a particular task can be impacted in a negative way. Let's just focus on GPS, for example.
有些人描述的那样可怕。你知道，你读到头条新闻，为什么互联网正在扼杀你的记忆，或者互联网是如何毁掉你的记忆的。我还没有看到很多证据表明这种情况已经发生。所以，你知道，我看了关于谷歌的研究，通过Instagram查看照片的研究，GPS的使用，像媒体多任务处理这样的事情，我们可能会，你知道，被智能手机上的活动分散注意力，从而无法专注于讲座，例如。我得出的结论如下。我认为毫无疑问有证据表明，当我们依赖技术时，我们对特定任务的记忆可能会以负面方式受到影响。让我们只关注GPS，例如。
If I use GPS to get me from point A to point B, there is evidence in the literature that indicates that I will probably have worse memory for that particular route that I just took than if I navigate it on my own. I'd probably have a better memory for what I did because I'm more actively using my stored knowledge to get from point A to point B, as opposed to just relying on navigation. And there's even evidence from neuroimaging, a very nice study done in London from the group of Hugo Spears published a couple of years ago, where they took people on a tour of the London Soho district, and then the next day they scanned them while they were either using their memory
如果我使用GPS从A点到达B点，文献中有证据表明，与我自己导航相比，我可能对刚才走的特定路线的记忆会更差。我可能对我所做的事情有更好的记忆，因为我更积极地使用我存储的知识从A点到达B点，而不是仅仅依赖导航。甚至有来自神经影像学的证据，伦敦Hugo Spears小组几年前发表的一项非常好的研究，他们带人们参观了伦敦苏豪区，然后第二天他们在扫描他们的同时，要么使用他们的记忆
to kind of navigate, do a virtual navigation of the area they toured, or they could rely on a GPS-like device, two different conditions, the same people. And interestingly, what they found is that there was robust activity in the hippocampus that we talked about before in a couple of other regions related to memory, but only when people were relying on using memory to navigate around that area in London. when they're relying on the navigational aid, you weren't seeing that activation. So, you know, that suggests that that might be a reason why you would have, you know,
来导航，对他们参观的区域进行虚拟导航，或者他们可以依赖类似GPS的设备，两种不同的条件，同一些人。有趣的是，他们发现，只有当人们依赖使用记忆在伦敦那个区域周围导航时，我们在之前谈到的海马体和与记忆相关的其他几个区域中才有强烈的活动。当他们依赖导航辅助时，你没有看到那种激活。所以，你知道，这表明这可能是为什么当你依赖导航时，你会拥有
less memory for a route when you're relying on navigation. You're not engaging some of those key memory structures. So for a specific task, yes. But then we can ask, well, are there broader effects? For example, if I rely on GPS a lot, am I going to have a more general problem remembering routes or other kinds of spatial information, information in the domain of the GPS? And there's only, I would say, there's some suggestive evidence, but not much evidence, that the effects extend beyond the specific task. And then finally we can ask, well, if I rely on GPS a lot, would I have not only problems remembering routes in general, but maybe my entire memory system, memory for personal experiences, for facts, maybe it would be impacted in a general way. And for that, there's almost no evidence. So I think, yes, there is evidence that when we rely on technology, we may have worse memory for specific task. but there's very limited evidence that it extends beyond that.
更少的路线记忆的原因。你没有参与那些关键的记忆结构。所以对于一个特定的任务，是的。但随后我们可以问，好吧，是否有更广泛的影响？例如，如果我经常依赖GPS，我是否会在记住路线或其他类型的空间信息，GPS领域的信息方面有更普遍的问题？我会说，只有一些暗示性的证据，但没有太多证据表明影响超出了特定任务。最后我们可以问，好吧，如果我经常依赖GPS，我不仅会在记住路线方面有一般性问题，也许我的整个记忆系统，个人经历的记忆，事实的记忆，也许它会以一种普遍的方式受到影响。对于这一点，几乎没有证据。所以我认为，是的，有证据表明当我们依赖技术时，我们可能对特定任务的记忆更差，但几乎没有证据表明它超出了这个范围。
Another domain that I briefly mentioned that's relevant to this discussion is media multitasking. So again, I'm supposed to be paying attention to a lecture, but I'm distracted by what's going on on my smartphone. There's definitely evidence from studies like in the classroom and laboratory analogs that when you media multitask, not surprisingly, you're going to have reduced memory for the content. of the lecture. So again, a task-specific effect, just like having bad memory for the route on which you're using GPS. But suppose you're a chronic media multitasker, you do it a lot. Does that have a more general effect in memory? And again, I would say there's maybe suggestive evidence. So there have been studies that show that people who subjectively say, yeah, I do this
我简要提到的与此讨论相关的另一个领域是媒体多任务处理。所以同样，我应该专注于讲座，但我被智能手机上发生的事情分散了注意力。来自课堂和实验室模拟的研究肯定有证据表明，当你进行媒体多任务处理时，不出所料，你对讲座内容的记忆会减少。所以同样，一个任务特定的影响，就像使用GPS时对路线记忆不好一样。但假设你是一个长期的媒体多任务处理者，你经常这样做。这会对记忆产生更普遍的影响吗？同样，我会说也许有暗示性的证据。所以已经有研究表明，主观上说“是的，我经常这样做”的人，
a lot, tend to perform worse, for example, in remembering lectures than people. who say, I don't do that a lot. But what the research hasn't yet clearly shown is whether that's because people who have poor memory and attention abilities to begin with are the ones that end up doing media multitasking or whether it's media multitasking that causes these problems. So we really don't know yet. So it's a very interesting, important area. And we've been learning a lot about it, but we need to learn a lot more. Speaking of smartphones, we all walk around with them, and they all have cameras these days,
往往表现更差，例如，在记住讲座方面，比那些说“我不经常那样做”的人。但研究尚未清楚地表明，这是因为一开始记忆和注意力能力较差的人最终进行了媒体多任务处理，还是媒体多任务处理导致了这些问题。所以我们真的还不知道。所以这是一个非常有趣、重要的领域。我们一直在学习很多关于它的知识，但我们需要学习更多。说到智能手机，我们都随身带着它们，而且它们现在都有摄像头，
and everybody is constantly taking pictures and posting them, and that's sort of how we live our lives today, especially for younger folks. Do we know what that's doing to people's memories of the experiences that they actually had? I mean, I've gone to places with tourists who they're taking picture, picture, picture, picture. But are they really experiencing the place that they're very experiencing the place that they're visiting. Yeah, really important question as well. There is a lot of work on that,
每个人都在不断地拍照并发布它们，这在某种程度上是我们今天生活的方式，特别是对于年轻人来说。我们知道这对人们对他们实际拥有的经历的记忆有什么影响吗？我的意思是，我和游客去过一些地方，他们拍照片，照片，照片，照片。但他们真的在体验他们正在访问的地方吗？是的，这也是一个非常重要的问题。关于这一点有很多工作，
and I do review some of that in the update on Seven Sins. And again, it's kind of a somewhat of a complex picture, but there is evidence that when you pay a lot of attention to taking a photo, you may have worse memory for the experience as a result. If you're really just focused on figuring out the lighting and what's the best way to get the picture and stuff like that, then your later memory can suffer. It doesn't always suffer, but it's been shown that you can have a poorer memory when you really focus on things related to taking the picture. If you focus, for example, on, you know, trying to really hone in on a particular feature of an object and you really focus on the object, you may have pretty good memory for that. But activity, that's more
我确实在《七宗罪》的更新中回顾了其中的一些。同样，这是一个有点复杂的图景，但有证据表明，当你非常注意拍照时，你可能会因此对经历的记忆更差。如果你真的只是专注于弄清楚灯光以及拍出照片的最佳方式等等，那么你以后的记忆可能会受损。它并不总是受损，但已经证明，当你真正专注于与拍照相关的事情时，你可能会有更差的记忆。例如，如果你专注于，你知道，试图真正专注于物体的某个特定特征，并且你真的专注于物体，你可能对那个物体有很好的记忆。但活动，那更多
focused on getting the correct lighting, correct angles, stuff like that can impair memory. Now, you might say maybe it's just a function of the fact that when people take a picture, they know that they're going to be able to come back to it later on. So it's like a cognitive offloading, if you will. But you still see these detrimental effects even when people delete the photo right afterwards. And so they realize they can't come back to it. Another interesting question has to do with photo review. So looking at photos on Instagram and other kind of online platforms.
专注于获得正确的灯光，正确的角度，诸如此类的事情可能会损害记忆。现在，你可能会说，这可能只是因为当人们拍照时，他们知道他们以后能够回到它。所以这就像一种认知卸载，如果你愿意的话。但即使人们在拍照后立即删除照片，你仍然会看到这些有害影响。所以他们意识到他们无法回到它。另一个有趣的问题与照片回顾有关。所以查看Instagram和其他在线平台上的照片。
There are some beneficial effects of that because, as we discussed earlier, simply using a photograph to retrieve a past experience is going to strengthen that past experience. So there can be a beneficial effect of photo review. but actually going back to some work that was initiated in my lab way back in the late 1990s before social media platforms came on the scene, we were interested in the effects of photo review. And what we found is that, yeah, it can benefit your memory, but it can also impair memory for related experiences that you don't review. So if you have a photograph of vacation,
这有一些有益的影响，因为正如我们之前讨论的那样，仅仅使用照片来检索过去的经历就会加强那种过去的经历。所以照片回顾可能会有有益的影响。但实际上回到我实验室在1990年代末社交媒体平台出现之前发起的一些工作，我们对照片回顾的影响很感兴趣。我们发现，是的，它可以使你的记忆受益，但它也可能损害你没有回顾的相关经历的记忆。所以如果你有一张度假的照片，
vacation and you repeatedly retrieve exactly what happened in that event, related information from that vacation that you don't retrieve may suffer. And this is an example that's been established of something been established in laboratory studies known as retrieval-induced forgetting, where if we retrieve information about a past event, it strengthens that event, but related information that's not retrieved, suffers. And I think that there's a real application to photos there as well. Have you looked at all into the question of recovered memories? I ask because it's very controversial in psychology, whether people, you know, can remember 30 years later that they
度假，并且你反复检索那个事件中究竟发生了什么，你没有检索到的那个假期的相关信息可能会受损。这是实验室研究中确立的一个例子，被称为“检索诱导遗忘”，即如果我们检索关于过去事件的信息，它会加强那个事件，但没有被检索的相关信息会受损。我认为照片在那里也有真正的应用。你有没有研究过“恢复的记忆”的问题？我问是因为这在心理学中非常有争议，人们是否，你知道，可以在30年后记住他们
were abused as a child and a whole lot of controversy as to whether such memories like that are accurate. Do we know? Yeah, I think we know and brought outline. So this is something I dealt with at length in the Seven Sins of Memory 2001 book, because that's one that controversy was really active. And, you know, I think by conclusion at that time was some recovered memories can be accurate, recovered memories that occur outside the context of therapy and outside the context, without suggestion. People can be spontaneously reminded, typically of events.
小时候受到虐待，而且关于这种记忆是否准确存在很多争议。我们知道吗？是的，我想我们在大纲上知道。这是我在2001年《记忆的七宗罪》一书中详细处理的问题，因为那个争议当时非常活跃。而且，你知道，我认为我当时的结论是，一些恢复的记忆可能是准确的，在治疗环境之外和在没有暗示的情况下发生的恢复的记忆。人们可以自发地被提醒，通常是关于事件的。
that they just haven't really thought about for a while. And that's not an unusual occurrence. Memory of a past event that I haven't thought about for a while may be triggered by a queue. And that seems to kind of fit a lot of the recovered memory experiences that people report that can be corroborated, those spontaneous reminders. And it's not necessarily the case that those memories were actively repressed. it's just something people hadn't thought about for a while, and then it can be reminded of later. On the other side of that, there's also, you know, there was even by 2001 a lot of evidence that many of
他们只是有一段时间没有真正想过。这并不是一种不寻常的发生。我有一段时间没有想过的过去事件的记忆可能会被线索触发。这似乎在某种程度上符合人们报告的、可以被证实的许多恢复的记忆体验，那些自发的提醒。而且这些记忆不一定是被主动压抑的；这只是人们有一段时间没有想过的事情，然后以后可以被提醒。在另一方面，还有，你知道，即使到2001年也有很多证据表明许多
these recovered memories are not accurate. The ones that are cued by suggestive influences turn out to be memories that are very difficult to corroborate. So I think that that controversy has died down quite a bit over the last 20 years. It was much more heated in the late 1990s than it is now, perhaps because as more knowledge of the potential corrupting effects of suggestion on memory has become available, people who are engaging in suggestive practices that led to these spurious recovered memories are not doing it as much. And I do provide a little update on the recovered memories controversy in my chapter on suggestibility in the new seven sins book and how some views have changed over the years. But to me, what's most striking is that
这些恢复的记忆是不准确的。那些被暗示性影响所提示的记忆结果证明是很难证实的记忆。所以我认为那个争议在过去20年里已经平息了很多。它在1990年代末比现在激烈得多，也许是因为随着更多关于暗示对记忆的潜在腐败影响的知识变得可用，那些从事导致这些虚假恢复记忆的暗示性做法的人不再那么做了。我确实在我的新版《七宗罪》书中关于暗示性的章节中对恢复的记忆争议提供了一些更新，以及一些观点多年来是如何改变的。但对我来说，最引人注目的是
there's so few of these cases being reported. Not zero, but it's nothing like the eruption that occurred in the early to mid-1990s. And I think there's a reason for that. I think that individual who are engaging in suggestive practices that had the potential to lead to false memories are not doing it as much. So you don't see these cases to anywhere near the degree that you did 25 years ago. One of your more recent research interests is the link between memory and planning for the future. What's the connection between those two things? And why is this an important connection to make?
报告的这些案例太少了。不是零，但这与1990年代初到中期发生的爆发完全不同。我认为这是有原因的。我认为那些从事有潜力导致虚假记忆的暗示性做法的个人不再那么做了。所以你没有看到这些案例达到你25年前看到的程度。你最近的研究兴趣之一是记忆与规划未来之间的联系。这两者之间有什么联系？为什么这是一个重要的联系？
I think it's important for a few different reasons. The connection empirically is that many of the same processes that we engage when we remember a past experience are engaged when we project into the future and imagine a possible experience. For example, in my lab, we first began on this line of work systematically about 15 years ago, put people. in the scanner, they were given simple word cues and asked to either remember a past experience or imagine a future experience related to the word cue. So for vacation, if you were in the memory condition, you would try to retrieve a specific memory of a vacation from the past few years. In the future condition, if you were given that same word cue, you would imagine some vacation that might occur to you in the next few years. We compare brain activity.
我认为这在几个不同的方面都很重要。从经验上讲，这种联系在于，当我们回忆过去的经历时，我们所参与的许多过程，与我们展望未来并想象可能发生的经历时所参与的过程是相同的。例如，在我的实验室里，我们大约在15年前开始系统地进行这项工作，让人们进入扫描仪，给他们简单的词汇提示，并要求他们要么回忆过去的经历，要么想象与该词汇提示相关的未来经历。例如，对于“度假”这个词，如果你处于记忆条件下，你会尝试检索过去几年中关于度假的具体记忆。在未来条件下，如果你得到同样的词汇提示，你会想象未来几年内可能发生的度假。我们比较了大脑活动。
in those two conditions to a control condition where you'd be given the same kinds of cues and asked to perform tasks that involve both visual and conceptual processing, but didn't involve remembering or imagining a specific event. And what we saw was very striking increases in a network of brain regions during remembering the past and imagining the future that were nearly, not entirely, but nearly identical, suggesting a strong link between. between the two. And indeed, that work was in part stimulated by an interesting observation from the 1980s that was made by Endel Tollving, an eminent memory researcher, my old PhD advisor and colleague at the University of Toronto when I was there back in the 70s and 80s. And this
在这两种条件下，我们将其与一种控制条件进行了比较，在控制条件下，你会得到同样的提示，并被要求执行涉及视觉和概念处理的任务，但不涉及回忆或想象特定事件。我们所看到的是，在回忆过去和想象未来时，大脑区域网络出现了非常显著的增加，这些区域几乎（虽然不完全）相同，这表明两者之间存在强有力的联系。事实上，这项工作在一定程度上受到了20世纪80年代一个有趣观察的启发，该观察是由著名的记忆研究员恩德尔·托尔文（Endel Tulving）做出的，他是我在70年代和80年代在多伦多大学工作时的老博士导师和同事。而这
concerned an amnesic patient, a severely amnesic patient known in literature by the initials KC, who I did a lot of testing with. And one day, both Tolving and I, were testing KC. We were seated across a testing table from him, and Tulving asked him the seemingly innocent question, what do you think you're going to be doing tomorrow? And KC. just sat there and drew a blank. Just sat there and said, gee, I can't really conjure up any image of what I'm going to be doing tomorrow. It was the same kind of response you would get from him if you asked, what did you do yesterday. He can't tell you what he did yesterday. And after a while, he could be prompted to say, well, I'd have breakfast, I'd have lunch.
涉及一位健忘症患者，一位在文献中以首字母KC闻名的严重健忘症患者，我曾对他进行过大量的测试。有一天，托尔文和我都在测试KC。我们坐在测试桌对面，托尔文问了他一个看似天真的问题：“你觉得明天你会做什么？”KC只是坐在那里，脑子一片空白。他只是坐在那里说：“哎呀，我真的无法想象明天我会做什么。”如果你问他“昨天你做了什么”，他也会得到同样的反应。他无法告诉你他昨天做了什么。过了一会儿，他可能会被提示说：“嗯，我会吃早餐，我会吃午餐。”
He would sort of run out a script. But what was striking from that observation of KC, it suggested, again, a link between remembering the past, imagining the future. Eventually, that led to the FMRI study that I just described. And a bunch of other work from my lab and other labs has shown this tight inner linkage. Now, one of the reasons I think this is important theoretically has to do with a critical point about the seven sins of memory that I made way back in 2001 and have elaborated upon more recently. And that's the idea that these memory sins, while they can be annoying in everyday life,
他会照本宣科。但从对KC的观察中，令人震惊的是，它再次暗示了回忆过去与想象未来之间的联系。最终，这导致了我刚才描述的功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）研究。我的实验室和其他实验室的其他大量工作也表明了这种紧密的内在联系。现在，我认为这在理论上很重要的原因之一，与我在2001年提出的关于“记忆七宗罪”的一个关键点有关，并且我在最近做了更详细的阐述。这就是这样一个观点：这些记忆罪过，虽然在日常生活中可能很烦人，
are not necessarily bad things in memory. Rather, I see them as kind of the costs that are associated with benefits in the memory system. So, for example, maybe the clearest example of that, would be persistence that I talked about earlier. We have persisting memories of emotionally arousing and traumatic events, but we want our memory system to preserve a very vivid record of experiences that could threaten us in the future. So that's a good feature of memory, that we do have very strong memories for highly arousing and emotional events. And generally, those are the things that we remember vividly, but they can also keep us up at night. How does this relate to imagining the future, well, if we look at memory as something that's not necessarily just
并不一定是记忆中的坏事。相反，我将它们视为记忆系统中与利益相关的代价。例如，最明显的例子可能是我之前提到的“持续性”。我们对情绪激动和创伤性事件有持续的记忆，但我们希望我们的记忆系统能够保存可能在未来威胁到我们的经历的生动记录。所以，我们对高度激动和情绪化的事件有非常深刻的记忆，这是记忆的一个好特征。通常，这些是我们记得最生动的事情，但它们也可能让我们彻夜难眠。这与想象未来有什么关系呢？嗯，如果我们把记忆看作不仅仅是
for reminiscing about the past, but for using past experience to plan ahead to simulate future events, which is kind of the way I look at it, memory is useful to the extent that it can help us predict, anticipate, simulate the future. For a memory system to be helpful as a guide to future thinking, we need it to be a flexible system. we need to be able to recombine bits and pieces of our past experience to simulate novel upcoming events, because after all, the future is rarely identical to the past. So one of my arguments over the past 15 years has been that one of the reasons why we have memory errors, certain memory misattributions, where we mix up elements of different events,
为了回忆过去，而是为了利用过去的经验来提前计划、模拟未来事件，这正是我看待它的方式。记忆在能够帮助我们预测、预期、模拟未来的程度上是有用的。为了让记忆系统成为未来思维的指南，我们需要它成为一个灵活的系统。我们需要能够重新组合过去经验的碎片，以模拟新颖的即将发生的事件，因为毕竟，未来很少与过去完全相同。因此，过去15年来我的论点之一是，我们出现记忆错误、某些记忆归因错误（即我们混淆了不同事件的元素）的原因之一，
is because our memory is built so that we can use it to simulate future events. We need a flexible system that allows us to recombine different aspects of experience, and that very flexibility that I would argue makes memory useful for simulating the future can also lead to certain kinds of memory errors. And I go over some of the empirical evidence now that's mounted over the last 10 or 15 years, years that supports that idea that there's a link between this flexible ability to flexibly recombine elements of past experience, which is a good thing for simulating the future and other adaptive aspects of memory, but it can also lead to memory distortions and errors.
是因为我们的记忆被构建出来，以便我们可以用它来模拟未来事件。我们需要一个灵活的系统，允许我们重新组合经验的不同方面，而我所说的这种灵活性，使得记忆对于模拟未来很有用，但也可能导致某些类型的记忆错误。我现在回顾了一些在过去10到15年里积累的实证证据，这些证据支持了这样一个观点：这种灵活地重新组合过去经验元素的能力之间存在联系，这对模拟未来和记忆的其他适应性方面是有好处的，但它也可能导致记忆扭曲和错误。
Last question, taking us back to the new edition of your book. Can you say what you think has been the biggest change or advance in our understanding of memory? in the 20 years since you published the first edition? That's a really good question. What I would like to be able to do is go through each of the seven sins and say what I think is the most important thing. I would, you know, from where I sit, I think it relates to this last point I was making.
最后一个问题，带我们回到你的书的新版本。你能说说你认为自你出版第一版以来的20年里，我们对记忆的理解发生了什么最大的变化或进步吗？这是一个非常好的问题。我希望能逐一回顾这七宗罪，并说出我认为最重要的事情。从我的角度来看，我认为这与我刚才提到的最后一点有关。
That in 2001, yeah, I try to argue for some of the adaptive aspects of memory errors, but that argument was mostly based on theory. I incorporated evolutionary theory and a variety of conceptual considerations, but there really wasn't much experimental support for that idea. And now 20 years later, and this is I go over a lot of this stuff in the book, now there is. So to me, I think that's one of the biggest advances. We now have a lot more experimental support for this fundamental idea that various kinds of memory errors actually reflect adaptive aspects of the system. That would be the thing that I would single out, although there's evidence for each of the seven scenes that I think has been very
在2001年，是的，我试图为记忆错误的一些适应性方面进行辩护，但那个论点主要基于理论。我结合了进化论和各种概念上的考虑，但实际上并没有多少实验支持这个想法。而现在20年过去了，我在书中回顾了很多这方面的内容，现在有了。所以对我来说，我认为这是最大的进步之一。我们现在有了更多的实验支持这个基本观点，即各种记忆错误实际上反映了系统的适应性方面。我会特别指出这一点，尽管我认为我提到的七宗罪中的每一项都有证据，这些证据一直非常
important and instructive. Well, thank you. This has been very interesting and illuminating. I'm sure that our listeners are going to learn a great deal about their own memories from this. Thank you. I hope so. I enjoyed the conversation. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts,
重要且具有启发性。好的，谢谢你。这非常有趣且富有启发性。我相信我们的听众会从中学到很多关于他们自己记忆的知识。谢谢。希望如此。我很享受这次谈话。你可以在 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 或你获取最喜爱播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。请给我们留下评论。如果你有关于未来播客的评论或想法，
you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiion. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以通过 speakingofpsychology@apa.org 给我们发电子邮件。那是 Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，后面是 @apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Condayan。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。